لا يوجد بمثل هذا الامر
سابق اذ لم نرى في السابق اي شركه في
وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي تم مسائلتها
ودفعت تعويضات
لضحايا
الفظائع الخطيره
[موسيقى]
ما يمثله هذا التقرير هو محاوله
لربما محاسبه طرف واحد في خلقه لانه خلق
البيئه التي ادت الى تلك الفضائع هذا
التقرير هو
جزئيه مهمه من الاحجيه الكبيره الامر تطلب
سنوات من البحث عن الحقائق والتحقق من
المعلومات من معلومات حول التطهير العرقي
وايضا الدور الذي لعبته منصات التواصل
الاجتماعي كفيسبوك
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
اعتقد اننا سنرى هذه الشركات
الالكترونيه سيتم مسائلتها لجرائم التي
عانى مثلا وليس هنالك اليه كافيه يمكنها
ان تساءل او تحاسب الشركات
الالكترونيه تجاه الخدمات التي تقدمها في
بلد اخر
[موسيقى]
نعم بامكاني مثل هذه التقارير تكون مفيده
لان هذه الشركات ملكيتها خاصه لكن في
الكثير من الحالات مثل ماده يعني هذا
الامر ان اصحاب ملاك الاسهم بامكانهم ان
يمتلكوا اسهم وبامكانهم ان يصوت من الذي
سيكون في مجلس الاداره وما هي القرارات
الكبرى التي تتخذها الشركه خلال هذه اليه
ملكيه الاسهم او الحصص بامكاني ان يكون
هنالك نوع من المسائله حول تاثير هذه
الخدمات التي توفرها شركه